[Music]
hello my name is mark hernandez and i'm
going to talk about bringing cannabis
testing in-house be sure to select the
right limbs for your extraction lab
well in-house testing is not required
federally however the states be fair in
their requirements many instructional
laboratories have started establishing
in-house testing facilities to maintain
quality standards save restructuring
costs and reduce compliance tasting
failures
in this talk i will tell you why it is
essential to set up an in-house testing
lab and how lamps can optimize in-house
workflows
let's start by defining what is a
structure
extraction it's a process by which the
most important compounds are extracted
from the plant
these extracts can be used to make
edibles oils peels pills tinctures etc
the cannabis extraction process uses
volatile organic compounds to separate
the target chemical compounds from the
plant it could be cannabinoids
flavonoids terpenes and others
the cannabis extraction process has five
main steps the number one is collecting
and milling basically it is a process by
which distorted material the cannabis
reduces to fine and consistent particle
size just like gravity
the second step is the extraction
process itself distraction process can
use different solvents
such as butane or co2
the third step could be done
before or after destruction it's the
activation or the decarboxylation
the reason for a decarboxylation is that
the active cannabinoid in cannabis is
the thc8 the acid but this compound is
not actually psychoactive
so the decarboxylation
is caused by the slow heating process to
obtain the thc which is a psychoactive
um ingredient or compound in the
cannabis so it's the the component that
will give the expected effect for your
product and your customers
the fourth step is when the restation
the term winter comes because it's stone
at low temperatures and it's basically
the precipitation of unwanted lipids
from the extracted product
this can be escaped depending on what
the final construction method will be
and the fifth step is the third party
testing this is an independent testing
by a lab that is not involved in the
process
at each each step we recommend that you
must perform internal tests after the
extraction step if you want to do
another internal decarboxylation you can
do a real time testing to see when the
process is complete and after going to
license before shipping by testing and
at each step you can streamline the
entire process using good manufacturing
practices so your final products have
a reproducible kind of cannabinoid
profile
and you can optimize with the amount of
time needed for each batch of steps so
you can run as many laws as possible
with your existing instrument set
now let's see the forms of cannabis
extracts there is crumble there is
batter shatter death blood crystalline
dry step rosin and bubble hash
most of these forms are end products and
that can be sold directly to the
customers and are actually using bay
pins
they can be added for smoking this this
leg is generally then used as an
ingredient to make some other products
and it could be something simple as a
baked pan
or it could be something more in
like complicated like an edible like a
gummy or a chocolate
cannabis extract has multiple uses and
benefits and may be consumed
in different ways depending on the
indication and purpose
for example the olsen features these
liquids usually
are infused with pvd or thc and plays
under the tongue with a dropper
oils and centers are a good choice for
anyone who can take a pills or capsules
painful motions are topical and used to
treat muscle and joint pain
the capsules and peels are used for
systemic treatment of scissors disorders
or digestive dish
the edibles could be gummies or
chocolates they are horrible they're
pourable they're discrete and tasty
the baking it's the inherent by price
thc oil
and is the fifth fastest way to
experience the effects
here's the first reason why a cannabis
instruction lab will want to set up an
in-house testing facility
let's imagine that you have your own
instructional app
doom is followed of workflows like this
on the slide you receive the cannabis
you do the extraction process using like
associates like co2 then you do the
carboxylation the purification and
enrichment with some terpenes to make a
product i don't know for pain relief for
example
finally you send your finished product
whatever it is like a cream
to do to an
third party lab and it turns out that
it's a test failure after all this
process there is a test failure in the
final step
so this represents a huge financial loss
for your extraction company
which will they have to destroy the
product or put back into a new
instruction which it is very expensive
at least to our deal
so you'll want to do everything you can
to minimize this failure rate
if your final product is rejected by a
third-party testing lab at the end you
will have large associate codes so you
will have to make a new extraction or
discard the product there will be a
delay in the delivery and your customers
will not very happy and income will be
lost
for example time if you were having
tests
different aspects of destruction
say you want the initial product to be
test for potency for example
if you send that out to a third-party
testing lab it can take several days on
average depending on your estate and the
back look
this will slow down the whole process
you have to store all the materials for
the next steps while you are waiting for
the results of the test
last but not that long i'm sorry it's
another form of time delay you are
operating based upon the queue that is
in a third period testing lab and there
is the crunch time
so for example when argon legalized the
recreational use for cannabis the state
had a very vital out and they were only
approved two recreational testing lab in
the entire state
there was a tremendous backlog and the
structures were stuck because it would
take months for them with only two labs
in the state to get the third party
approval
so the first benefit for setting up your
own in-house testing lab is that you
save all the restriction costs and you
get your results faster
so let's see what's the formulation this
is a process that enables cannabis
brands and manufacturers to develop
projects for target physiological
response
when it comes to formulation the dose
must be established and one of the dose
well is the potency or the amount of phd
that your product contains
but it is also the whole cannabid
profile some of the cannabinoids are
better for medicinal effects than others
so you also need to ensure the security
of your label
if you advertise a paperless product
well you need to make sure that the it's
cannabinoids
interpretation profile support
and also the adverse patient's reaction
so the legalization of cannabis in
several states
has brought several challenges for
canada structures due to the increase in
scrutiny they are required to get the
product test for an entire house of
parameters to ensure costume health and
safety
like heavy metals pesticides microtoxins
or microorganisms can jeopardize
patients to help and
can bring liability to the manufacturer
if the manufacturer is not testing the
extracts properly so more tests can mean
more time wasted waiting for the results
and if the sample falls the whole
illustration processes two commands
again
grenoble for example is a terpene that
is found natural in lavender it's
produced in rosemary and smells very
good and it has antioxidant properties
it leads to mental alertness in animal
models and it's highly effective as an
antidepressant so if you want to create
a brand of extras that target the
specific conditions like antioxidants
it's at the height and on the market you
need to be very careful with your
formulation
so the second benefit will be to control
the complete cannabinoid profile of your
final product you can get consistent
dosage and formulation rabid onset of
action because depending on what is in
your final product it has different
absorption rates you get metabolic
predictability and improve safety and
effectiveness
so the third reason is dmp is good
manufacturing practices all can have
this destruction lab should be gmp
complaint
how do you follow dmp in the cannabis
industry well it's
very similar to the pharmaceutical
industry if you start with the sop
you need to have an slp for each step or
your manufacturing process this includes
the extraction side as well as the
testing site so you wanted your slp to
be optimized and you want all your
people to be trained and follow them
from inaccurate documentation of work
for compliance and traceability every
sample that you run need to be trashable
back to a quality control sample like a
sag or a duplicate or a blank whatever
it is it's part of the
17025 compliance on the third party and
local testing site
properly maintained facility and
equipment this means performation
and maintains a first schedule it gets
even more complicated as we go
later because a lot of analytical
instruments such as lcms
or dcms will have multiple subcomponents
and each of one of which has its own
schedule for calibration and maintain
this brings us to the third benefit
which is higher deals because using
trend analysis you can optimize the
amount of time you spend in the
destruction process the carbo-election
process and the wing theorization
process you get better product
consistency by controlling each step so
that you get the same potency in the
same cannabinoid profile and your final
product will be also consistent
furthermore it will reduce the
reliability since you are able to test
right from the beginning of the process
of the process for pesticides heavy
metals microscopic bacteria ethereal
so as we see the benefits are in each
step of your process in your instruction
right at the beginning you can tell the
true potency of the flower which has
been given to you by the grower you can
look at your extraction efficiency and
keep working on improvement so you can
see in which step in your process you
are losing the thc so you can optimize
it for that
in the post processing the main
post-processing step as we saw is the
carboxylation you wanted to determine in
real time when to stop the carboxylation
process so you need to measure
how much of the product is
decarboxylated in real time and this
only can be done having an in-house
testing law
and in the formulation when you have a
formula you want that every batch
followed your formulation
if there is a variability in the
starting materials like if they have a
slightly different cannabinoid profile
slightly different potency well you can
adjust this in destruction process so
that your m product meets your
formulation
to do that you need an in-house testing
lab that will tell you after what steps
you had a lower potency that you
expected so now in the next step you
have to use a higher concentration in
order to bring the produces back up it
helps
maintain the constancy with the final
formulation
so we have seen all the benefits of
having an in-house testing facility in a
cannabis distraction
it's the only way you're going to be
able to avoid the third-party compliance
testing failures and all the delays that
come with it furthermore you can do
formulation and follow gmp
now let's see how our limbs will help
you with all of that
well alex can help in so many ways it
can assure the quality of cannabis
samples there is an sov for how you
should be preparing samples or any type
of tests you're going to do
a limb securely manages sops and it
tracks maintain in calibration of
testing equipment as well as instruction
equipment it helps you manage documents
stop training meet gmp requirements we
will see how
testing and instruction labs have a lot
of instruments for analytical testing
instruments needs to be calibrated and
maintained
you can set the number of days before
the schedule calibration or maintain
state you would like to receive a
reminder nlms can send your menu to
initiate family actions like call to the
technician and schedule the calibration
or they maintain
each instrument component may have its
own calibration and maintain states
for example here on this slide you can
see that this asylum instrument has
three subcomponents which you can see
listed on the right
it just does have its own calibration
and maintains the schedule so if you
were doing this manually you will have a
booklet of your instrument calibration
with no alerts so it's much better for
the laboratory manager to do this in a
limb so
it's actually getting alert and you know
ahead of time when an instrument needs
to be calibrated and maintain it so you
have plenty of time of schedule
testing calibration medical associate
dots you need to have an srp for how
test and calibration should be done
these are generally provided by the
instruments manufacturers
this is
the challenge is because this is a new
industry so the instrument manufacturers
keep updating the testing and
calibration sops associated with any
instrument
when they issue a new one you need to
ensure that every technician gets
retrained on it
and only the latest calibration and
testing sop comes up
a lymph can do all that for you you can
see here that we had a particular
version and then we replaced the version
with the latest version a limb will only
have the latest version that comes up so
that when the tag transition comes to do
the calibration the technician is
following the latest calibration method
but there are no errors here with
obsolete sop
traceability is essential for 70 or 25
compliance in a third-party testing lab
and it is really useful in an in-house
testing life
testing lab as well
if someone asks how do we know that the
test results you provide was performed
on an instrument that was properly
maintained and calibrated the limbs will
show that possibility
when was the test done and when was the
previous calibration done and of course
there is an sop that was followed for
that calibration the most recently so
you have a fully traceable record
showing that your instrument was
calibrated and maintained when you run
that sample
manage documents with linux this is all
your srp so the second thing that will
come up in
in the same liability is when the test
was done with the covet sop file this
will show only the latest srp was
available at the srp that was used for
any particular task
manager staff training and competency
all your staff needs to be trained for
each step of your extraction process and
each of the steps of your
testing process
here you see training program
in the lab safety training
we have some staff some did well and
some
not so well
islands can generate a custom train and
competency matrix this matrix helps
laboratory managers quickly visualize
the competency level of the staff basing
on scores
and they cannot find analytical tasks
for the joining staff and provide
additional training to the incompetent
staff
as part of the 17-25 and gmp you can say
that juris traction is only being done
by laboratory technicians who are found
to be competent and properly trained for
that particular process
manage quality control samples with a
lens any time you do a test you need to
have traceability back to a qsa sample
these are your spikes or your duplicates
and length with you mixing between the
samples to ensure that you are getting
accurate results
a lens can help you to manage qc samples
and their test results with ease it is
part of the quality assurance and if
there is a question regarding the
ability
of a test result say whatever
there is a pesticide for example beyond
the acceptable limit you can show that
you respect uc sample with a known
concentration of pesticide and it was
accurately quantified in the qc sample
so you can assure that if the pesticide
was present in the test sample it will
have been detected
and also ensure that the potency is
correct if you say that ph level is like
a 15 percent it is
and you know this because the qc sample
were able to correctly identify the thc
concentration
so it is important
to be able to generate the custom
certificate of analysis a lens can help
you to do generate custom codes
in the preferred layout with it and flag
out
specifications as results this is very
important because it's different in each
state so it is important to have a
custom a certificate of analysis to
different states and different clients
instrument and software integration can
have a destruction lab for some testing
on several samples on their day-to-day
manual transfer of analytical data for
instruments to link its error pro
and reduce laboratory efficiency for
minimizing the test turn around time and
for maintaining data integrity it is
important to automate the data transfer
process and a good limit can be
simply integrated
with analytical instruments for
bi-directional transfer data thereby
reducing turnaround time and eliminated
genes or transcriptions errors
so as you can see the benefits of
implementing a cannabis lumps in an
in-house testing lab are numerous
increased just in results and the
productivity and increased quality and
lower cost
and finally the extraction lab is happy
we can observe a reduction in complaints
failures and high through put the higher
fee yields a wider product range through
reformulation
and repetition for consistency among
customers
so thank you very much for your
attention
you